[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba ben Emine Fidan
Öncelikle bugün bu akşam burada sizlerle
beni buluşturan tedx platformuna ve
Tetik Ankara ekibine teşekkürlerimi
sunmak istiyorum Ayrıca biraz da
teşekkürler kendimden bahsetmek isterim
müzik öğretmeniyim aynı zamanda yaklaşık
bir buçuk yıldır sosyal medyada müzik
alanında içerikler üretiyorum
ve bu bir buçuk yıllık emeğini Şu an
burada aldığımı düşünüyorum Umarım
keyifli bir akşam olur sizler için de
iyi dinlemeler diliyorum
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Koca Konak
[Müzik]
Ey an
ma Yarim ah
nasıl
edeyim Başımdaki
[Müzik]
amman amman
dost yoldan
gel yargına
[Müzik]
orada bir güzele Vurgunum
lar
yok
orda boylu bir gözene Vurgunum
[Müzik]
Çok teşekkür ederim
sıradaki şarkım sözleri Cihan barbur'a
müziği ise değerli Üstat Cahit Berkay'a
ait olan Selvi Boylum Al Yazmalım ile
Sevgi neydi Sevgi emekti diyoruz
[Müzik]
tuttum elin
sır
tı değmiş gibi
[Müzik]
olan
sevdiğime yol versin Bu dağ
lar rüzgarlı ovalar dağılan Yağmurlar
Al Yazmam
Serdi başka el de sevmek
dostluktur dilde
git uçuşan yaprak
[Müzik]
boş Kimse düşerim
dar gelirim arada
dön bak bana
yoksan yoktun Asya
imar
da sırf
bana yoksa
boştur Asya
[Müzik]
Çok teşekkür ederim
sıradaki şarkının anlamı benim için çok
büyük sözleri
şairimiz Pir Sultan abdal'a ait müziği
ise Muhteşem Yüzyıl dizilerinin
bestecisi olan Aytekin ataş'a ait şu an
sizler için seslendireceğim Umarım
beğenirsiniz
[Müzik]
Ben böyle
Yare
Mecnun edip şöyle
[Müzik]
sadıktan sonra
alemin Bağında
[Müzik]
büyüdem benim gülüm
solduktan sonra
alemin
Bağında bülb
[Müzik]
üller midem benim gülüm
solduktan sonra
Coşkun su
lar
çağlamayan Gönlüm
bağlamayan
[Müzik]
ya benim
şu hal
ağlamak daha
ağlamazsın
öldükten sonra
Benim şu hal
ime ağlamayan
daha
alamazsın
öldükten sonra
[Müzik]
Pir Sultan
'a sürem
[Müzik]
Bu yolu seni
Kamil'i Olmuşam
[Müzik]
kur ister Yağmur
yağsın isterse
[Müzik]
Nidem ben
ummana daldıktan sonra
ister
[Müzik]
Yağmur ister sev
olur Nidem ben
umuma dağıldıktan sonra
Coşkun sular gibi
[Müzik]
çağlamayan Yar
Gönlüm
e bağlamayan
ya benim şu hal
ime ağ
lamak daha
halam
öldüten sonra
benim
hal
ime ağlam
Ayan daha
varsa
sonra benim
şu hal
[Müzik]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] daha
öldükten sonra daha
[Müzik]
öldükten
sonra
çok teşekkür ediyorum
tekrar konuşmamın en başında da söz
ettiğim gibi tedx platformuna ve
tedx'teki tüm gönüllü arkadaşlara çok
teşekkür ediyorum
[Müzik]